what's going on guys this is Rob if you
guys enjoy my content make sure you hit
the subscribe button and make sure you
hit that little bell so you never miss
out on my sexy voice
you know I just discovered who post
Malone is and that guy makes really good
music I really like the musical postman
like it's pretty enjoyable what's going
on guys and welcome to comics explain if
you guys are new here if you guys are
not new here then welcome back yes
welcome back we are covering Black
Panther stuff specifically we're
covering Black Panthers suit also known
as a Black Panther habit so this is an
interesting idea and in truth while the
Black Panther sued is like part and
parcel to his character were going all
the way back to his first appearance and
Fantastic Four number 52 in 1966 in
truth it's been around for much much
longer than that within the Marvel
continuity and in fact it stems all the
way back to the founding of the Panther
cult which we discuss in our video on
the history and the nature of Wakanda if
you guys are curious about that you guys
will find that down in the description
now the head of the Panther called is
basically given the title of Black
Panther and part of having that title is
receiving the Panther habit which is the
ceremonial Sioux that the Black Panther
wears to designate him or her as the
religious and political head of Wakanda
so when you hear the term Panther habit
it's just another way to refer to the
Panther suit that the Black Panther
wears but regardless what's really
interesting about the Panther habit is
that because what Conda is the most
technologically advanced country in the
world the suit has evolved from just a
ceremonial relic into a technological
marvel that has a myriad of different
features and the most distinguishing
feature of Black Panther suit is that
it's laced with the metal vibranium
which is really the foundation for most
of the cool stuff that the suit can do
now those are guys who haven't fought in
my channel for a long time probably know
what vibranium is but for those of you
guys who are new vibranium is one of
these strongest metals in the Marvel
Universe and in addition to being
virtually unbreakable it also absorbs
all vibrations from stuff like bullets
and punches and it can absorb magic
hence the reason why it's called a
vibranium really it amplifies magic
raagh is the kind of absorbs and
amplifies magic but due to a meteorite
landing in Wakanda around 7,000 years
ago it's one of only two places on earth
the vibranium can be found and so
because the Panther habit is laced with
vibranium is exceedingly durable but the
momentum of any object that strikes it
is immediately negated which is also a
cool feature and so if you shoot black
panther with any sort of projectile like
an arrow or even a bullet it's just
gonna simply come to a dead stop when
the suit absorbs the kinetic energy and
the bullets just gonna fall down so
technically he's bulletproof
sounds like there's just a really hard
metal and bullets just bounce soft and
said the energy is absorbed by the suit
and the bullet just falls to the ground
and that's really about it and this is
anything with momentum as long as it's
not more durable as long as it's not
stronger than vibranium if black
panthers hit with it it'll absorb the
energy of whatever that object is and it
won't really stop him at all now
backtracking to what I said a minute ago
if there's two places on earth where
vibranium can be found one of which is
what Conda and the others in the Savage
Land which is a jungle that lies in the
middle of Antarctica but the two
locations yield two different types of
vibranium true vibranium comes from
Wakanda while the Savage Land produces a
different isotope of vibranium also
known as an T metal that has its own
unique property that emits a kind of
radiation that breaks down the molecular
bonds of metals that it comes into
contact with and kind of turns him into
sort of a liquid like state now in
addition to true vibranium Black Panther
has incorporated a t metal into a suit
in the form of claws that could extend
from the end of his gloves that he uses
as an offensive weapon and can even use
them as projectiles now undoubtedly the
question that people are gonna ask I can
almost guarantee it is can antarctic
vibranium anti metal take out adamantium
the answer to that question is yes this
was covered in Avengers vol 3 issues 22
to 23 during an Ultron I think was
Ultron unlimited and essentially what
had happened as Ultron's body was made
of adamantium and what they ended up
doing was basically using anti metal to
essentially Pierce's a body structure
and then beat the crap out of them which
is how they did have they defeated that
version of Ultron so yes
anti metal can cut through adamantium
that is something that can't happen now
one of the other cool things about Black
Panther suit are the boots that he wears
and in fact it features these boots they
can basically create force fields from
vibranium within their soles which
actually allow Black Panther to do a lot
of different things like fall from great
heights and land on his feet without
suffering any real harm so much like Ben
and all those guys from ScrewAttack kind
of established in the Batman vs. Black
Panther video he is very much like a cat
in that regard that is very much true
but if Black Panther is going fast
enough these force fields can actually
allow him to climb up walls or run
across the surface of water the Black
Panther can also use these boots both
offensively and defensively and has even
been able to stop the momentum of a car
that's been thrown at him with the boots
that he wears now there are a few more
features of the suit that make Black
Panther who's already an expert fighter
in a supergenius
and even more formidable fighter first
the suit can
change its appearance to resemble normal
street clothes to allow black panther to
blend in with his surroundings or even
become completely invisible the suit
also contains a device that allows to
travel to teleport but it isn't really
clear as far as how far he's able to
turn off a teleport and how he's able to
travel in this way you know how far he's
able to go when he teleports but it's
one of those things where it's just kind
of contextual and based on you know
whatever particular story is being
written at the time but the Black
Panther suit also contains vibranium
energy daggers which has a blade of
energy that's generated by vibranium and
can either function as an actual blade
or thrown as a projectile now Black
Panther can choose to set these blades
to either stun or to kill his opponents
and he can regenerate them so he pretty
much has a limitless supply of these
things now these blades can also be
molded into other shapes like Spears or
sights and finally black panther can
generate a shield made of hard light
they can protect him against most
attacks from most enemies that are out
there and so yeah this suits pretty
impressive I mean it allows Black
Panther to battle opponents that are far
more powerful than he is in fact he was
able to withstand punches from the
Incredible Hulk
while wearing the Panther habit and he's
battled Erik he'll monger who was a
villain that was strong enough to kill
an elephant by charging at it with his
shoulder he battled him for 13 straight
hours and black panthers even survived a
punch from namor the sub-mariner while
he was possessed by the Phoenix force
which is one of the most powerful forces
of energy that are out there so yeah
Black Panther suit makes him incredibly
powerful this combined with like the
enhanced abilities that he has as a
really as a Black Panther is kind of the
representative representative on earth
of the Panther God along with a super
genius makes him like what are the most
formidable people out there like on
almost any level it's crazy how powerful
he is but nonetheless I figured let's go
ahead and throw this out there the
pseudo Black Panther explained or
something along those lines but if you
guys are new here to comment explain
make sure you hit the sub button to
become part of the robb core if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and my food is done cooking so I
will catch you all later peace
[Music]